informally we can think of information
as some message stored or transmitted
using some medium when you paint you are
representing your message using a
continuous pattern with the seemingly
endless numbers of possible forms you
are free to express yourself when humans
began developing writing systems we
naturally had to divide our world into a
finite number of atomic units which we
express using symbols now any written
language can be thought of in this way
messages are formed by arranging symbols
in specific patterns let's return to
3000 BC and explore two ancient writing
systems first in ancient Egypt we had
hieroglyphics a priestly form of
communication reserved for governmental
fiscal magical and religious purposes it
was practiced by a select few writers
known as scribes and writing was
generally unintelligible to the common
people the symbols themselves broadly
fall into two categories word signs
which are symbols that represent a
single meaningful concept and sound
signs these symbols represent chunks of
sound now the total number of different
symbols in common use was over 1500 and
if you divide all of these symbols into
word signs versus sound signs we find a
much smaller portion of sound signs
there were around 140 sound signs and of
these only 33 represented distinct
consonants a tiny fraction of all of the
symbols and use at the time the medium
used to store the symbols was primarily
rock and this was ideal for durable
inscriptions allowing messages to travel
into the future mobility was not a main
concern when communicating messages in
this way
however a new physical medium for
storing symbols was emerging at the time
along the Nile silt deposits left from
flooding made the surrounding land
extremely fertile and one of the many
crops they grew was to Pyrus it could be
sliced into strips and these strips were
then soaked and weaved together and
finally pressed allowing the natural
sugars to act as glue after several days
it dried and formed an almost weightless
tablet this medium was ideal for sending
messages across greater spaces rather
than the more durable inscriptions
focused on time now this shift towards
cheap portable mediums for storing
symbols coincided with the spread of
writing into the hands of more people
for new purposes gradually as people
began to write more on papyrus the
symbols evolved to suit more rapid
writing this led to a cursive script
known as higher attic for example here
is the world's oldest surviving Surgical
document it's written in higher attic
script dated to around 1600 BC now these
symbols were based on hieroglyphics
however the pictures were simplified to
match the swiftness of writing an
ancient shorthand also the number of
common symbols in use began to shrink
down to around 700 by escaping from the
heavy medium of stone thought gained
lightness a marked increase in writing
by hand was accompanied by the
secularization of writing thought and
activity this led to a new writing
system called demotic around 650 BC
which was devised specifically to
facilitate the ease of rapid writing for
example this text is known as a marriage
contract and is one of the earliest
known examples of demotic script it's
interesting to notice that there was a
dramatic reduction again in the total
number of symbols with this new system
roughly 10% of the total number of
symbols used before this was due to a
shift towards the use of phonetic
symbols or sound signs over word symbols
or meaning signs and the new simplicity
meant that children could be taught to
write at a young age we see the same
pattern in other cultures let's return
back to 3000 BC and visit Mesopotamia
where cuneiform was the writing system
originally used for fiscal purposes as
it was a powerful method of tracking
depth and surplus commodities before the
invention of coins for example here is a
document recording someone's stock of
animal hides and this type of writing
evolved to suit other needs for example
this tablet contains a recipe for bread
and beer and here's another tablet which
contains a legal document now originally
the writing system was used by the
Sumerians and there were over 2,000
different symbols in use which could
also be divided into word signs and
sound science Akkadian gradually
replaced Sumerian as the spoken language
and here is the earliest known
dictionary from 2300 BC it contains word
lists in Sumerian and Akkadian and this
was discovered in modern Syria when it
was adapted by the Akkadians and fitted
to their language they reduced the
number of symbols to around 600 and they
did this again by moving towards sound
signs again we see both hieroglyphics
and cuneiform using several hundred
sound symbols and their more evolved
forms and as writing systems escaped
their formal usage and spread to more
and more people the soil was ripe for
the invention of a brand new writing
system for the people one of the great
discoveries in the history of writing is
dated to around 1700 BC the Sinai
inscriptions were found in the Sinai
Peninsula and they were about 20
feet apart this was important because
each picture denotes a consonant sound
and no word signs are used when sounded
out correctly the letters would produce
words in ancient Semitic although not
fully deciphered this message appears to
be of the form name rank and Prayer the
two words deciphered are chief and God
this innocent example was part of a
writing revolution creating meaning by
merging sound signs only by 1000 BC we
arrive at the phony ssin alphabet which
emerges along the Mediterranean used by
the Phoenicians who were a maritime
trading culture the Phoenician writing
system was based on the principle that
one sign represents one consonant and it
was used to write a northern Semitic
language containing only 22 symbols
total these symbols chosen to represent
these sounds were often bull road from
hieroglyphic pictures so that the
letters name began with the letters
sound for example mem which stood for
water became what we know of as the
letter M Alf which stood for ox became
what we know of as the letter A but the
secret power of this alphabet unknown to
its inventors was that it did not need
semitic speech in order to work with
modest adjustments these miraculous
letters would be fitted to diverse
tongues of Europe India and Southeast
Asia carrying literacy around the globe
yeah this was a source of the Greek and
later Roman alphabet forms we know today
the idea of an alphabet is a powerful
method for transmitting and storing
information realize it doesn't really
matter what the symbols are or how you
choose them or even what languages in
information is just a selection from a
collection of possible symbols and over
time we have always looked for faster
more efficient ways of transporting
information across greater and greater
spaces and when we try doing this using
new mediums which travel faster than any
human or animal an engineering problem
presents itself
you